hello everybody get started only five
minutes later she's actually pretty good
so thanks for coming and getting settled
so my name is Josh Capon and I'm the
Associate Director of edl Center for
Environmental Law on policy and you are
all here for part of our year-long
speaker series we we have two parallel
tracks with speaker series one is our
bookshelf series we're bringing authors
mat Hoffman actually isn't author but he
is also here for the other track where
we've been exploring novel and created
climate policies so some of you may have
seen in the fall that we had Peter later
and James Cameron come to campus to talk
about different aspects of how to
address the climate problem from
focusing more on agriculture as a medic
as a wave issue to the bottom of
governance that James Cameron spoke
about so tonight we have professor Matt
Hoffman from the University of Toronto I
want to say a couple things about Matt
before I also mentioned another event
that you should think about attending
coming up later this week so I've had
this opportunity there's a lot of
speakers on the last several years that
I've been here matt is the only one I've
actually known before they arrived on
campus so Matt was my professor of
political science and my advisor as an
undergraduate at the University of
Delaware he is now at the University of
Toronto which is a shame University of
Delaware which I still have more of
allegiance to than Toronto but it but
it's good for Canada and good for
Toronto of course so I'm really excited
to have not here and the really time
he's working on something that is is
right in line with the kind of work
we're doing the Congress because we're
trying to bring in so I don't want to
say a lot about Matt's work except to
say that as I mentioned he he has
written a book which is cloud governance
at the crossroads and what if focuses on
is what the early stages I think that
what he's been taught more about tonight
which is catalyzing political pathways
to hopefully better climate governance
so we've talked about you know bottom-up
approaches as I said
that agriculture is an approach and
we're talking about many other
approaches kind of finance metrics and
so forth but the idea of this project
which map and described in real detail
is to think about how we get politics
changing not just them not the specific
action the specific mechanisms that are
we're using to address climate but the
political processes hopefully that was
more or less straight so I'm gonna let
him tell you more about that but before
I do I just want to mention that there's
going to be tomorrow where I put the
note C is it I haven't organized so I
want to make sure I get the details
right so tomorrow there's going to be a
high level a high-level panel of
academics and practitioners talking
about kind of governance in the US the
title of the pylons for the future of us
climate advocacy and it's moving 6pm and
bowers 6pm it is tomorrow is that right
then yeah 6 p.m. tomorrow in Bowers and
I'm going to tell you who the folks on
the pine logs they're pretty impressive
people Thetas got cold when you've
probably overdose made her name in
climate politics relatively recently
very ready Peter Barnes and let them at
least somebody else who I actually
happened to know Abby Billy who works
for Earth just assume i worked with
closely my previous life doing more
divine mental advocacy work so with that
I want to turn it over to Madame thank
all of you for joining us great thank
you so much for having I'm really happy
to be here it's nice to see Josh
although I realize that you're probably
wondering how someone so young could
have a student Josh's ten years ago but
I'm really pleased to see how well he's
doing and I'm really glad to be here so
what I'm going to talk to you today a
little bit about is a project that's
ongoing and so by which I mean don't
hold me to the things that I say here
because we're in the year two of a six
year project that we're trying to figure
out what we've got up here catalyzing
transformative pathways to
decarbonisation and essentially what I
want to talk to you today about is how
we're trying to make sense of the
potential politics of decarbonisation
and this it's a collaborative project
I'm a p.i and I'm a COPI I steven
bernstein at the Arusha toronto and
we've got collaborators from a number of
different places including your own
ben cash or and grand mauled who's also
in the audience i believe as well from
Carleton University as well as some
folks at Colorado State and Durham
University in the UK and luned and
Ottawa University up in up in Canada and
so essentially what we're talking about
is what is the potential on the
political side for moving towards broad
decarbonisation and I'll spare you the
suspense we don't have the answer yet we
don't have the answer yet but we have
some ideas and we're still being worked
out so I really look forward to hearing
your thoughts on what we're working on
and so where we start our analysis is
what do we need right what do we need we
need pathways to decarbonisation right
our economy our energy systems our
transportation systems are all locked
into carbon right this is a concept that
a guy named unruh put together this
notion of carbon lock-in right so we're
locked into the carbon system whereby
multiple cultural political technical
and economic dynamics reinforce the
continuing use of fossil fuels all right
so take for instance driving driving is
an activity that is locked into the use
of fossil fuels it's a default behavior
in most of North America and elsewhere
right and it's reinforced technically
right we have significant technology
that is sunk into having us use fossil
fuels to get around in cars it's
reinforced economically and that we have
entire industries and sectors that are
based on the production of automobiles
that use fossil fuels in extracting
fossil fuels in setting up filling
stations for for cars right but those
are the kind of obvious pieces of
lock-in but it's also locked in
culturally right with the mythos of the
American freedom of using using
automobiles right the growth and value
of suburbia is part of locking in fossil
fuels and autumn ability and even
politically it's lock did we very few
politicians win elections by promising
to build fewer roads or make driving
more expensive
and so but to avoid the worst impacts of
climate change right we need to rapidly
disrupt carbon lock in right we need to
rapidly move towards decarbonisation
right you know the science varies on
this but sometime in the next decade or
so we need to at least peak and then we
need to move rapidly away from carbon
use by 2050 and so if that's what we
need we need pathways decarbonisation
and we need them relatively quickly the
next question we asked ourselves in this
project is well what do we have to work
with right if we need decarbonisation
what do we have to work with to get
there and there's a couple of
traditional answers that are actually
not that useful right so one of the
things we have to work with is the
multilateral process right this is the
traditional notion of what we have to
work with the mega multilateral process
this is a picture from Copenhagen in
2009 my feelings about the utility of
the multi-level process should be
evidenced by the fact that the most
recent photo I have from the one I
attended was 2009 right and let me say I
think that the multi-level process is
valuable for a lot of reasons and I'm
happy to get into that in QA but it
won't or cannot put us directly and
quickly onto a path towards
decarbonisation all right now last fall
it got a bit of a shot in the arm right
with the US China condominium and sort
of one of the major obstacles to the the
disputes or the debates at the
multilateral system seems to have a
little more hope now because China in
the US are in somewhat moving in the
same direction and an improving
environment for treaty-making can be
good for decarbonisation efforts but not
because the international community is
going to come to an agreement that sets
out the solution to decarbonisation but
rather because it can generate momentum
that can be taken up at other levels and
amongst other initiatives and again I'm
happy to talk a little bit more about
the china-us condominium in question and
answer if people are interested but the
takeaway here is one of the things we
have to work
it's multi treaty-making but it's not
necessarily the solution that we need
another thing that we have to work with
has been more recent we've seen a number
of reports coming mostly from economists
that we call that in our project we
think of as solutions oriented reports
right so this is the deep
decarbonisation pathways there's some
stuff coming out of the socio-technical
transitions literature there's the new
climate economy report and these tend to
be cost-benefit analysis at a very high
level laying out solutions to move
toward from where we are to where we
need to be in terms of solving climate
change right or moving towards in this
case deep decarbonisation right the
problem with this and I think that these
are valuable their valuable politically
they're valuable for providing cover
their valuable for showing that there
are economic benefits to be had to
working on climate change that it's not
just in the realm of costs to move
towards decarbonisation but we can
actually think about moving into the
realm of benefits from working on
decarbonisation but the focus of these
kind of reports is on the end state the
emotion that we have an end goal of
decarbonisation and we can look at the
policy prescriptions and show that by
cost-benefit analysis they are viable
ways to move ahead right and so in many
ways then decarbonisation in this
conceptualization has become a technical
enterprise if we just implement the
policies that are laid out in
cost-benefit analysis in these reports
we will move towards decarbonisation now
the problem with this and again I think
these reports are valuable and the
people that working on them are smarter
than I am and they're doing incredibly
good work right but the problem or the
disadvantage of this kind of approach is
that we don't get an analysis of why
some policies might be more palatable
than others we don't get an
understanding of how we can actually
implement today these solutions that
have payoffs in 2050
and even further and I think this is a
little bit more philosophical what these
kind of reports ignore is the fact that
decarbonisation is not a defined goal
beyond the banal sense that we won't be
using fossil fuels decarbonisation is
something that we defined by what we do
how we don't use fossil fuels what our
society that what a society that doesn't
use fossil fuels looks like what an
economy that doesn't use fossil fuels
looks like what an energy system that
doesn't use fossil fuels looks like
these are all relatively open questions
and further once we start to try and do
things to move towards decarbonisation
our understanding of what the end goal
is is likely to change decarbonisation
in many ways is something that we
discover along the way and these kind of
reports that have a broad look from 2015
to 2050 do not give that sense of what
the pathway even though this one is
called pathways what the pathway might
be so the focus of our project is that
if if we don't really have the multi
processor work with and if this is only
a start but doesn't get us to doesn't
get as far enough along the way as we
think that there's a third thing that we
have to look with to work with and
towards of moving towards
decarbonisation what we've seen in the
last 25 years is an enormous explosion
of for lack of a more precise term
climate governance initiatives or
experiments essentially all kinds of
different actors are starting to take
climate change action into their own
hands and so we've got things up here
like the Copenhagen city plan and city
networks like c40 and the city for
climate protection you get NGO corporate
alliances like the WWF's climate savers
program or the climate group you get
sub-national activity like emissions
trading here in the northeast of the
United States and Reggie right and so
you see a number of initiatives that are
working on climate change trying to move
us towards decarbonisation in relatively
small ways right
and so what we're trying to do in this
project is figure out how we get what we
need decarbonisation from what we think
we have to work with diverse globally
decentralized interventions that are
working on climate change but are
working so in very specific contexts
right now of course and this is probably
comic most you've seen step two is the
doozy right so we know what we need we
have to work with we know where we need
to get to but step two should be a
little bit more explicit and i have to
tell you after working on this for years
I still think a miracle needs to occur
right and so what we're trying to do in
this project is fill in step 2 all right
still in step 2 and we think that
there's three parameters for how we
could fill in step 2 how this miracle
can occur that we can figure out how we
get from experimental diverse relatively
small-scale activities to
decarbonisation in a broader sense and
the three parameters we have for
thinking about this is first that this
is a political question all right this
is a political question this is a
question of politics and that political
dynamics are crucial now that's probably
not too surprising coming from a
political scientist right I realize I am
NOT talking against interests here right
but our understanding is that technical
innovation is not enough and the
delimitation of cost-effective solutions
is not enough its political dynamics
that make some solutions viable and
others not viable right decarbonisation
again is not a preset destination how
decarbonisation is understood and how it
will be pursued is a political question
and so one of the ways we think about
how we get from what we need to or how
we get from what we have to what we need
is that it's a political pathway second
is that carbon lock-in is a fractal
phenomenon and that's a really jargony
thing so let me unpack that
bit essentially we're using the notion
of fractal in a metaphorical sense and
fractal systems have a characteristic
that what we call self similarity right
and so this is a picture of a fractal
system and what that means is that it
any level that you look at this picture
it pretty much looks the same right so
if you look at the whole system right it
looks very similar to if you just look
at this piece of the system right and so
fractal systems are to have what we call
self similarity right and so what we
conceive of is that carbon lock in these
reinforcing dynamics that make the use
of fossil fuels the default action right
arises because of fractal dynamics that
essentially we don't have theirs it's
nonsensical to talk about global carbon
lock-in because there's no global system
there's no global transportation system
there's no global energy system and yet
it's also makes entire sense to say that
we have global carbon lock-in because
all over the world we are locked into
the use of fossil fuels and so what this
fractal metaphor helps us to think about
is that global carbon lock-in and global
decarbonisation is actually arises from
the fact that we have mutually dependent
systems that have similar dynamics so
carbon lock-in in the city of Copenhagen
right is dependent upon global carbon
lock in for instance the city of
Copenhagen can't suddenly move to a no
carbon transportation system in some
ways right but that global carbon
lock-in happens because the city of
Copenhagen is locked into carbon the
state of Denmark is locked in to cope is
locked into carbon the city of New York
the state of New York what you have is
mutually independent systems that have
similar dynamics right our global energy
transportation and economic systems are
locked into carbon because
transportation energy and economic
systems that the municipal provincial
state and regional levels are locked
into carbon and what we think this this
is both a challenge and an opportunity
right there's both a challenge and
opportunity obviously if decarbonisation
is everywhere you know the adages things
that are everywhere are nowhere and it's
hard to figure out where to act on
things but because if we're right about
it being a fractal system we can also
say that efforts to disrupt carbon lock
in anywhere can have broader effects so
in other words if you can disrupt carbon
lock-in in the city of Copenhagen that
has the potential to start disrupting
carbon lock-in in the systems that the
carbon that the city of Copenhagen are
embedded in right and so we can
understand cut decarbonisation not we
don't have to think about
decarbonisation is something that
happens all over the globe all at once
we can think about decarbonisation as
taking disrupting carbon lock-in in
specific context specific places and
think about how that kind of activity
can catalyze moves towards
decarbonisation beyond those specific
systems right now our third parameter
for thinking about how we can theorize
that miracle is that what we're doing is
forward theorizing right and this is
where I the part of the part of the talk
where I tell graduate students to not do
a study like this because we are
essentially trying to study the future
right which is not something that is
readily study abul right we don't have
any successful cases of decarbonisation
on any meaningful scale right this is
just if we had decarbonisation this
would be much easier and so what we're
trying to do with our understanding is
develop a framework that helps make
sense of trajectories that interventions
are on that these initiatives are on and
the ways in which they might catalyze
broader transformation and so we're
going to look as I'll talk about a
little bit we're going to look at a
diverse set of cases how they got to
where they were and what's the potential
moving forward for them to catalyze
decarbonisation and so this is not a
classic social science study where we
look at some cases of decarbonisation
some cases of failed decarbonize a
and try and understand the difference
between the two so that we understand
what conditions get us to
decarbonisation instead we're looking at
a bunch of different interventions that
are attempting to disrupt carbon lock in
and try and understand the trajectories
that they're on and the processes that
they are engendering to see if we can
understand a little bit more about what
are the potential possibilities for
decarbonisation alright so again so
we're linking what we have to work with
with what we need and so we're trying to
think about these parameters and
understand how decarbonisation pathways
can be conceptualized and understood and
so in doing this and for simplicity's
sake what we do is we break down
decarbonisation potential into a couple
of different things right so we start
with our diverse globally decentralized
interventions and we say for
simplicity's sake that any system that
we're thinking about whether it's a city
whether it's a province or state a
corporate system or national system is
on a trajectory that can be moving in
one of these three directions right it's
a system that could be moving towards
reinforced carbon lock in all right so
that we could be trying to do things but
essentially we fail and we just end up
being more locked into carbon use than
we were before it could be moving
towards an outcome of improvement in
other words be a more efficient use of
fossil fuels but not really doing things
to get out of the use of fossil fuels or
we could be moving towards a system
transforming we could be moving towards
decarbonisation right and so our goal is
to understand how we get these kind of
different trajectories and again what we
observe empirically has been the
emergence of a diverse array of
interventions that seek to change the
trajectory of specific systems so we get
experiments like c40 that's trying to
change the trajectory of 68 of the
largest cities in the world we get
carbon labeling efforts that are trying
to change the trajectory of corporations
in various sectors we get the climate
group which is trying to change the
trajectory of cities by essentially
diffusing the norm of
smart cities we even get sort of more
traditional policy interventions like
the I'm sorry Colorado's new climate rsr
a new energy economy which is trying to
disrupt the system or the economy in
Colorado or the German push for
wide-scale use of renewables trying to
disrupt the economy and the energy and
transportation systems in Germany right
and so an intervention for us is this
conscious attempt to disrupt a current
system state a new policy and new
municipal climate action plan deployment
of a new technology when our framework
then has to be able to understand or
hopefully make sense of how the
trajectories that these diverse
initiatives are on internally so in
other words is Copenhagen actually
moving towards carbon neutrality but
then also how they can catalyze broader
trajectories towards decarbonisation
right and so that's this is a visual
representation of our of our model right
now and so on the your left we have the
intervention so pick your intervention
whether it's c40 or the Copenhagen
municipal climate plan or the climate
groups smart cities project all right
and so what we say is that any
intervention is going to engender or has
the potential to engender three kinds of
political effects right three kinds of
political effects it can alter it alters
the state of norms in the system and so
there's normalization around different
ways of acting on climate change it's
going to alter the capacity to act in
that system in terms of both knowledge
and technology and it's going to alter
the political coalition's political and
economic coalition's in that system all
right so in other words once you start
doing something there's potential for
these kind of political effects and
dynamics to get started so you can get a
shift in norms you get a shift in
capacity you get a shift in coalition's
right that once these political dynamics
start to occur what you then see is the
intervention itself has the potential to
scale up or become
are entrenched and both Graham and Ben
will recognize some of this language
from their wicked problems super wicked
problems work right that if you're able
to alter the norms in the system and
build capacity and build coalitions the
intervention will get bigger get more
prominence and will become entrenched in
the system that you're looking at and
then from this feedback is how we start
to see whether or not you're going to
get reinforcements improvement or
transformation trajectories out of that
system alright so let me pull some of
this apart a little bit so the system
effects are important right and so what
we have here is consider the recent
report from the Carbon Disclosure
Project it's an experiment that works
get fortune 500 companies to report
their exposure to climb at risk right it
highlighted how a number of heavy
industry hitters are now including
shadow carbon prices in their financial
planning essentially corporations like
GE Google Microsoft and even Exxon are
assuming that there's going to be a
carbon price in the future or including
the cost of carbon in their business
planning right so this intervention CDP
working to get corporations to report
their carbon risk has altered the common
sense of these corporate systems such
that they are now anticipating a
different kind of future right so you
get a normalization of climate policy
interventions can also build capacity
the skills tools and institutions and
knowledge to act so the pilot programs
in c40 this group of large cities that
they undertake around for instance
retrofitting buildings or facilitating
electric vehicles and designing
transportation systems provide knowledge
and best practices that can be spread
beyond the cities where they were
started up right and so you can get this
build-up of capacity to act now changing
the common sense and altering the amount
of capacity there is to act has a
potential to have profound political
effects when it comes to coalition's
right the potential is there for
building political and economic
coalition's that see that their
interests lie
in aggressive action on climate change
and as these grow it will be essentially
easier to move forward on larger and
more ambitious targets right essentially
what you're seeing here in coalition
building is that one of the key problems
in climate change is that losers from
acting on climate change know exactly
who they are and know exactly the level
of costs that they're going to have to
pay if we move aggressively on climate
change while winners tend to be more
diffuse right and so act these
interventions essentially help to
identify who the winners are going to be
for acting on climate change and get
them to network in a way that might lead
to some political change so these kind
of system effects these political
mechanisms that the interventions
engender when they're successful and
we'll talk about conditions for success
or different in just a bit lead to
scaling and entrenchment right scaling
an entrenchment essentially scaling up
is a key for these interventions to have
an impact that we might see as more than
negligible right if they contribute to
these dynamics then we expect that
interventions will scale up and become
entrenched and catalyze broader change
but scaling is not just a simple thing
we do have simple scaling some of these
interventions just get bigger right see
20 or C 40 I'm sorry started out as the
c 20 became the sea 40 and now it's
still called to see 40 but there's sixty
eight cities in it right there's a
growth imperative pilot projects and
neighborhoods need to become citywide
projects the Carbon Disclosure Project
needs to sign up most of the fortune 500
companies if it's going to have the
impact that they might like right and so
we can talk about simple scaling is
simply getting bigger and if they're
able to contribute to normalization
capacity building coalition building
these interventions have the potential
to get larger they also have the
potential to engender different kinds of
scaling something we call self-organized
scaling and modular isomorphic scaling
and self-organized scaling is really
kind of interesting I think of this is
building an ecosystem of acts
on climate change right and so when you
have an experiment or an initiative that
comes in it opens up all kinds of
political space for other kinds of
activity so think about this in terms of
the carbon offsetting markets right once
you start to get people making carbon
offset projects well what this did was
it opened up all kinds of space for
other initiatives how do we verify these
how do we set standards for carbon
offsets how do we measure them how do we
account for them and so once you get an
intervention starting to work in
particular areas you can engender the
growth of entire ecosystems of
interventions that are working on
Climate governance and we also see that
we can see scaling beyond the initial
cases and that's what we're talking
about with modular and isomorphic
scaling we have similar types of
experiments multiplied as either the
model of the experiment is copied
elsewhere or similar experiments pop up
in different places right and so here
what you have is the growth of city
networks for instance you have multiple
city networks that have emerged in
multiple places right and so you also
have the way in which different models
of experimentation so carbon labeling
for instance once you start to get a
working model of carbon labeling and the
Carbon Trust has a really interesting
model of labeling products for their
carbon footprint that can get taken up
by different jurisdictions the Carbon
Trust started a carbon labeling
initiative in the UK which is now being
adopted with some modifications in
France and Thailand and Quebec right and
so you can get scaling outside that
original set we also we also see
entrenchment right as these
interventions have political impact
right they begin to become locked in and
self reinforced you essentially you get
increasing returns to the actions that
we're talking about right and I'm
instead of talking about this in the
abstract I'll go through this in a
little bit of an example here in just a
little bit
right but essentially what entrenchment
means is that one see an intervention
starts working and if it's able to
engender normalisation capacity building
and coalition building right that
intervention becomes more and more part
and parcel of the system that you're
talking about and it becomes how the
system ax rather than something that is
just disrupting the system right so now
the arrows in this feedback that we're
talking about here reflect positive
relationships in other words as these
three mechanisms increase as we get more
normalization more capacity building
more coalition building that leads
interventions to scale up and become
entrenched in the jurisdictions where
they work right and over time it is that
relationship between the political
dynamics and the scaling and
entrenchment we think that helps to
understand why a system might move
towards reinforcement improvement or
decarbonisation right now this is just
looking at the interventions in a
particular system and one of the things
we're really interested in is how you
can get efforts that to disrupt carbon
lock-in in particular places catalyzing
effects of carbon lock-in in other
places and what we're excited about and
looking forward to hearing your feedback
on is we think that this exact same
process is happening in basically
anytime you have an intervention working
on carbon are working on decarbonisation
this process is happening but that they
can be linked right and so that
essentially what you have the potential
because of the fractal nature of this
system because these are mutually
dependent systems that interventions for
instance in Copenhagen generate this
kind of feedback relationship in
Copenhagen but also contribute to
interventions and how the politics works
in the state of Denmark and how
interventions work and the potential
they have to disrupt things in c40 right
and so what we like about this framework
is that it helps us to understand
and disruption of carbon lock-in in
specific places and the way that action
on climate change in specific places can
be catalytic elsewhere and if people
want me to go through that I can but I
think it'd probably be more useful to
talk about it in terms of an example
right and so what do we do empirically
what we looking at in this project again
because we have no cases of
decarbonisation what we're looking at is
as many and as diverse a set of
interventions as we can get right we're
looking at City action we're looking at
state action we're looking at national
action global action private action and
what we try and do is take a look at
what the target of the system is right
and they're trying to disrupt carbon
lock-in in a city is it trying to
disrupt carbon lock-in in an industrial
sector we try and trace once the
intervention gets started how it's
contributing to normalization capacity
building and coalition building we're
trying to trace how that relates or how
that helps or hurts the intervention
from scaling up and becoming entrenched
and then trace the links to systemic
trajectories now our goal in doing this
is that last part right what we'd like
to be able to do is translate our
knowledge that we generate and steps 1 2
3 into strategies for how we might
suggest however humbly what could be
done to move systems on two trajectories
towards decarbonisation right and this
is where we kind of know how to do one
in to where we're learning how to do one
and two we're really trying to figure
out number three and we hope this is
probably a little bit heuristic that if
we figure out one two and three really
well we'll be able to do number four
right I'll come back in seven years and
tell you if we can do that but we'll see
all right how are we doing this
empirically let me give you an example
right and so this is the city of
Copenhagen for those of you
no this is a famous part of Copenhagen
called new hound and the reason I do
this is I did a one of our cases is the
city of Copenhagen because they have a
municipal climate plan in Copenhagen the
city of Copenhagen has a plan to go
carbon neutral by 2025 right and within
that it's not just a slogan all right
they have initiatives around energy
around buildings around transportation
and they have a process in place where
they're moving from pre-analysis in each
of these areas to pilot projects to
citywide implementation now in most of
their sectors that they're working on
they're still in stage 2 in pilot
project area but essentially you know
going along our empirical area their
plan is to disrupt carbon lock-in in the
city of Copenhagen right and so what we
do then is say okay they have a plan and
they have a set of policies in place to
try and disrupt carbon lock in how is
that contributing to our political
dynamics right how are they essentially
or what does that plan do and so we look
at in terms of normalization right well
in terms of normalization they have
explicit stakeholder outreach both
citizen and corporate to sell the idea
of the sustainable city and economy
right the carbon neutral city is a
livable city the carbon neutral city is
good for business right and so they have
active parts of their policy is to
normalize the idea of a decarbonize city
right to actively engage with
stakeholders to change the common sense
around what a livable city is and what
the city of Copenhagen should be right
in terms of capacity building this
moving from pilot projects to
implementation they have an explicit
learning by doing approach city staff
and stakeholders are both learning how
to construct a carbon-neutral city right
now this differs by sector in the
building sector with retrofits they're
learning all kinds of really interesting
things they're learning how to bundle
projects they have an entire mapping
exercise so that they know what types of
buildings are where in the city because
different types of buildings
will require different kinds of
retrofitting right there also there for
getting construction companies involved
in the pilot so they learn how to do
retrofitting and so they have the
capacity to move beyond the pilot
project to do citywide retrofitting and
of course there's a political aspect to
this capacity building as well right
learning by doing is good politics
because it gets shovels in the ground
right it gets economic resources moving
in particular places and of course this
contributes to coalition building right
development of a clean tech cluster
initiative that complements the
municipal plan is one of the things that
really stands out in Copenhagen they're
explicitly selling carbon neutrality as
a new economic model right and building
economic coalition's that want to see
Copenhagen move beyond pilot projects to
citywide implementation now what we are
seeing is that the contribution of the
pilot projects and the city is
Copenhagen's municipal plan to these
political dynamics is leading directly
to the scaling up of ambitions and
entrenchment of this kind of action in
Copenhagen this plan has already
survived a change of mayoral
administration and the initiatives are
being funded now I won't say that it's
an easy fight at every budget meeting in
Copenhagen but they are being funded
incrementally and growing right the city
has taken over power generation for
instance and is building windmills all
over Denmark to offset its own
electricity generation and it's becoming
part of the city identity right if you
talk to people in Copenhagen this notion
of a sustainable city being a livable
city has become the new common sense on
the streets of copenhagen and scaling up
is occurring in the city as well as they
move again from pilot projects to
citywide implementation especially you
see this in transportation with the bike
infrastructure as well right but perhaps
more importantly and if we think about
this so that's what's going on in
Copenhagen I can
use this framework to understand what's
going on in Copenhagen right but frankly
no one cares if Copenhagen decarbonize
a--'s be nice for the million people
that live in Copenhagen right but that
is globally negligible shall we say
right and so if Copenhagen is going to
be more than a feel good story and good
for Danish people that live in
Copenhagen and you know I'm married to a
Danish American who has all kinds of
family in Copenhagen and so it's
wonderful for me I get to go see eat
pastries and see wonderful windmills
right but if it's going to be more than
that then we have to understand how
action in the city of Copenhagen might
catalyze efforts towards decarbonisation
contribute to this kind of process
elsewhere right and so we can also see
this in terms of an external cycle right
so in terms of normalization and
capacity building the city's actually
undertaking a conscious outreach
strategy on its own and through its
participation in c40 the group of large
cities where Copenhagen is a prominent
member essentially they're selling the
idea of sustainable cities in their
network right and the knowledge to
achieve the disruption of carbon lock in
they're trying to disseminate their best
practices through the network of c40
cities so this is happening on a I would
call a city to city path right where and
this is propaganda from the city of
Copenhagen but i'll quote it anyway
copenhagen is unique large enough for
its climate solutions to be interesting
in an international context now that's
promotional material to be sure right
but it's real policy within the city of
Copenhagen they're diffusing c40 is
essentially diffusing what Copenhagen is
doing to the 68 members of the c40 this
is also this college I'm sorry this
normalization and capacity building is
also happening on a corporate path right
one of the interesting strategies that
Copenhagen has to scale up their
ambitions within Copenhagen is to sell
what they're doing in Copenhagen outside
right they are really trying to sell
this no
of the Danish economy as a clean tech
economy right they're really trying to
build coalitions of Danish corporations
that buy into the green economy as a way
to not only reinforce what they're doing
but to catalyze change outside it right
and so this you get this double action
we're selling the Copenhagen model
actually ends up entrenching the actions
within the city of Copenhagen and so
just last fall copenhagen in new york
city announced a c40 facilitated
partnership to establish a danish clean
tech hub in new york city all right and
I'll just quote from the from the press
release that this will help New York
City capitalize on Danish tech savvy
while providing Danish companies access
to the New York marketplace right and so
essentially what you've got then is if
city of Copenhagen is up on top there
that cycle is the city of Copenhagen
well this is the trajectory that the
city of Copenhagen is on is having
influence on the political dynamics that
c40 is also contributing to right and so
because you have these modular systems
that are mutually dependent right
decarbonisation efforts in the city of
Copenhagen have the potential to
catalyze or contribute to the political
dynamics that are happening in other
systems right now as you may have
gathered from whether the confusing
pneus of this framework is there's lots
of work to do here yet right it's just
beginning and we've got a number of
cases on the go essentially what we're
trying to do is learn as much as we can
from a hugely diverse range of cases and
this is just the first two rounds of
cases we're eventually going to try and
do about 25 to 30 cases right we're
trying to learn lessons across them on
especially on unintended consequences
the importance of resources the
importance of counter coalition's how
the interventions adapt themselves adapt
over time
right and we're learning a number of
lessons we don't expect to come up with
a set of conditions that are going to
work across all of these interventions
in fact that's not the point of what
we're doing what we're trying to do is
come up with a way of understanding the
process or trying to come up with a
general way to make sense of
transformation right and we keep going
back and forth between theory and P ryx
and theory all right but let me briefly
conclude with the question of whether
this is all worth it right i started off
the talk by saying asking what we have
to work with and then quickly dismissing
the multilateral process and sort of
large-scale cost-benefit analysis
reports but it's a fair question to ask
if studying relatively small scale
interventions are relying on relatively
small scale decentralized interventions
is also a smart strategy either in terms
of academically or practically right the
way I think about this is I use a
traffic jam analogy I'm sure at least
one or two of you have been stuck on
i-95 at some point right and I don't
know about you but when I'm stuck in a
traffic jam the great temptation is to
get off on the side streets right and
try and go around it and try and try and
find an alternate route right there one
of the reasons that is tempting at least
for me and again you guys are all
probably more patient than I am one of
the reasons that's tempting at least for
me is the illusion of forward motion is
powerful I really like to feel that I'm
making progress right so getting off on
the side street might be completely the
wrong thing to do it might be much
slower right but I'm moving I'm going
forward I'm dynamic right and so I the
worry right the worry is that
concentrating on small scale initiatives
rather than putting our political
efforts into trying to get a centralized
national response or a centralized
global response is getting off of
i 95 and getting lost in the streets of
New Haven right you're moving but are
you moving forward right I do though
think and let me add end on a hopeful
note I think that that analogy isn't
correct I actually think that getting
off on the side streets is more
appropriate because I 95 if they to
really stretch this metaphor assumes
that there is one way to get to
decarbonisation right one way to get to
decarbonisation and I think it's worth
having a go as this quote talks about
because decarbonisation is not a single
thing right we are going to have to
transform multiple systems at multiple
levels in order to really move away
societally and globally from fossil
fuels right and so thinking about how we
can get disruptive change in specific
particular places and how that
disruptive change in specific particular
places can catalyze broader
transformation i think is where our
energy really needs to be both
politically and academically and again
i'm speaking completely in my own
interest because this is the project i
want to work on and so you can take that
with a grain of salt but with that i
will close and thank you for attention
and look forward your questions no sorry
you're talking about successful
interventions scaling up becoming
entrenched I'm wondering if you've
thought about how things scale up and
become entrenched when they are
distinctly not successful like the
international negotiation process which
has been going on for 20 years and has
not been success but I think most would
agree that it's become entrenched in it
now you know we're stuck a traffic jam
so let me let me talk about that in
particular way we had a great PhD
student hey miss Van
did a really interesting case on the
carbon label of the carbon trust that I
talked about and if you look at the
intended consequences of the carbon
trust right that what they wanted to do
was get product level carbon foot print
labels on every product in the UK right
and they signed up Tesco which is the
big supermarket there that signed up
Pepsi they got all these people signed
up and then they realize that doing
product level carbon footprinting is
enormously difficult and expensive right
and so and so Tesco dropped out Pepsi
dropped out right this is so if you just
stop their enormous failure did not
scale up right but not all the products
in the UK have carbon footprint labels
right didn't become entrenched it wasn't
that the UK said yes carbon product
level labeling is what we need to do
right and so but failed intervention
right system reinforcing right except
that if you look at what happened in
terms of the unintended consequence it
was actually really interesting and so
companies that were working at the pilot
phase on trying to measure their
products carbon footprint right found it
to be enormously helpful in terms of
finding where their most expensive
emissions work and they found them in
really unexpected places and so one of
the examples that Hamish talks about is
a potato chip company right did this
analysis on where its emissions came
from and found that they thought they're
our biggest submissions where it's going
to be transportation getting the
potatoes to their fact during the potato
chips to the storage it turns out their
biggest emissions were coming from the
frying and that's because of the way
they were buying potatoes they're buying
potatoes on the basis of wet weight
instead of dry weight and so the
incentive for farmers was to keep their
potatoes and humidified storage and so
the potatoes were really wet and wet
potatoes take a lot longer to fry than
dry potatoes and so they're using a lot
more energy heat up the you see how this
goes right and so what's happened is
that because of this move
to do carbon footprinting label put
carbon footprinting a product level is
what scaled up is not that every product
has a label but what is scaled up and
become entrenched in some corporate
sectors is supply chain management are
based around carbon right and that then
has had the impact that other countries
have started to ask the carbon trust
well how did you get people to do this
and this is where the carbon trust
methodologies for measuring these things
are now starting to spread in a totally
unintended way didn't scale up or
entrench the way they thought it would
and it was a failed intervention for its
intended consequences but has generated
some decarbonisation trajectory from
unintended in an unintended way now as
eclectic was really intrigued by the
metaphor of the fractal think about
carbon locking and one one thing that
the metaphor didn't quite capture for me
is this notion that the degree of carbon
lock-in is going to be the same in all
parts of the system or in all levels too
bright and so I guess I would have
imagined that the parts of the system
that are most locked in will also be the
parts that are least likely to have a
climate experiment and so I motion that
is like should we be confident that sort
of we can scale up from disrupted
grassroots or the low level type
disruptions or might be I guess also
need to have top down right so imagine
like the carbon tax PC or EP right these
are top down disruptions right yeah well
bc carbon tax is really interesting is
that top-down or is that bottom up right
its top down in bc but its bottom up if
you consider that it's a provincial
action within a federal system right and
so I think you're right that the fractal
metaphor starts to break down when you
talk
that doesn't break down but it becomes
more complicated when you talk about
diversity in the sort of modular systems
right Quebec looks very different than
that New York and New York looks very
different than California California
looks very different than BC right and
whether or not I have to think about
whether systems that are more locked
into carbon are less likely to have sort
of environmental interventions I'm not
sure I mean United States is very locked
into carbon but it is one of the most
innovative when it comes to the
existence of experiments across the
United States precisely because there's
been no federal action so what you've
seen is a fomenting of interventions and
experiments at the local and state level
but the fractal the the part that's
interesting is that where this breaks
down some if I can oops right is that we
don't know you're absolutely right then
we don't know that we think that carbon
block and dynamics look similar in this
cell as they do with this one in the
sense that they're in the broad sense
that there are reinforcing dynamics that
make fossil fuels the default option now
the degree to which it's locked in is
going to be different in these different
cells right and the connection between
them might be very diffused right city
of Copenhagen is going to be very far
removed from from new haven in terms of
how the what's the relationship between
them all right I don't want to take the
metaphor too far mostly we think about
it as a both a justification for
studying multiple systems right and a
way to conceptualize the connection
dependence between them but in actually
doing the analysis we have to take into
account the hugely diverse context in
each of the cells of the of the fractal
system it's probably not a very
satisfying answer but we're working on
looking for guests roughness why didn't
you know me the dominant metaphor began
with the metaphor that the roller
comments problem kind of funny would
have one kind of the ice somewhere else
irrational because know that you're our
system therefore we must have a little
treat this is both the dark red you're
saying actually it's the wrong man yes
okay let me just yeah as you said
absolutely right the atmospheres of
global Commons emissions reductions is a
commons problem decarbonisation is not a
common problem okay we have great things
which are happen is it fair say than
that where the pre-visualization say you
know is the free rationals eat ramen
suffragist harder on different sales
this question must immerse the initial
trigger is Norman Norman one is you can
have to put chair pose a problem and I
was wondering that's true
original motivation yes you can bring a
little spice in your model the original
others to be normal for you oh look keep
on keep on the low actually also be a
place to spark experiments okay not
really there's no tree because the first
normal operation yes and so I would push
back a little bit say I'm not sure that
all of these interventions are entirely
normatively based in fact I think we
lose if it did so I think that some of
them like some of the cities surely they
have interested citizens that are
pushing cities to do things well some
cities are acting because Copenhagen is
acting because they think it's going to
be really good for their economy right
in other cities are working you know the
co-benefits for acting on some of this
stuff are really important and I think
that it's actually easier to sell some
interventions on the basis of
co-benefits than it is on the basis of
of climate but that said I think a lot
of the interventions do have that
normative impulse behind them and I
think that you're absolutely right and I
always come across as being anti
multilateral which is actually the first
thing true I've been absolutely be the
first one popping the champagne corks if
Paris led to a really cool binding
agreement that it's not going to happen
but it I'd be the first one cheering
right but I think that we have
misunderstood what the role of the
global level can be in climate change we
have we have this model in our head and
it's because the multilateralism model
that when states face trans national
problems that can't be solved within
their borders you set up a treaty that
lays out the solution that they can all
agree to to implement right that works
for lots of different kinds of problems
it doesn't work for a problem as complex
and as multi-level as climate change but
that doesn't mean that we don't have
there's not a rule role for them I think
we need to change our idea of what the
role of the multi
process is I think it is a normative
role I think it is setting aspirations
hi I think that it needs to be more of a
facilitating role than a solutions
generating role in other words if you
know Germany is working on renewables
and Denmark's working on renewables or
we have three different sub-national
carbon markets in the United States and
we have six municipal level carbon
markets in China and we have the EU ETS
a role for the international system is
to facilitate and coordinate amongst
initiatives and to smooth out problems
that happen because we have stuff
happening in different places right and
so you can have much more of a sectoral
focus you can have much more of a
facilitated focus you can have the
global ago sure the best things come out
of oval negotiations last appears was
the agreement to go for two degrees
right even though that there's no
binding nothing about two degrees but
that has become part of the lexicon that
has become part of the understood
aspiration of what we should be aiming
for and that becomes part of the
motivation for acting and all kinds of
these different levels so I think you're
absolutely right it's just that we have
to change our mindset about what the
possibilities for the multi-level
process and what what treaty-making is
good for what treaty-making is not good
for
i think is very stimulating concept at
the heart of what you're working on so
the point where i found a theorized
weaker and i'm telling you this because
i think you can make it stronger prob
haven you're talking so much about
that's a big assumption well is your
talk about scaling out right that you
have some kind of innovation let's say
in copenhagen and those types of
innovations you're talking about are
many different types so maybe saw our
technology maybe some of them are
policies maybe some of them are
behaviors and what are the conditions
under which these innovations that we
can use that term loosely locally
actually scale out because it seems like
there are conditions in which like a
technology lets a tesla and invents a
car and then that connect car can be
sold in a lot of other markets that's a
pretty easy spillover but if China is a
carbon market in one kind of way Reggie
doesn't another kind of way does that
necessarily spill over so I think
thinking a little bit more about the
types of changes that are happening and
that ability to spill over to different
places would be really useful because I
don't think all kinds of actions have
that same spill over capacity don't open
your locally constraint yeah I think
that's absolutely correct I don't know
what the conditions but I want to but I
want I want to complicate what you said
a little bit there because I also i want
to be clear that I'm not talking about
simple diffusion it's not that what the
city of Copenhagen is doing is going to
be copied in New York and is going to be
copied in other c40 cities right and so
what I'm so my theoretical answer to
that is that what's scaling out so
scaling up is different scaling up is
how things get bigger and more
entrenched in the place where they
started right but scaling out is a
matter of how what you do in one place
contributes to the political dynamics in
another place whether it catalyzes the
emergence of another
vention itself right and so that would
be more of the self organized scaling
where you open up a little you do
something and that opens up political
space for someone else to do something
right or whether it contributes to how
another intervention is already working
right and so and the reason I say I
don't have the conditions is I think
that those conditions for when that's
going to happen are awfully contingent
upon the context within which that takes
place and so I think the best is because
I'm not that smart the best that I'm
going to be able to do is understand
this process and the conditions that
you're talking about are going to be
contingent ones and I'm actually okay
with that I think that it's okay for me
personally if I can understand how if
the upper left is Copenhagen how that
generates interventions and how it
contributes to the political dynamics of
other interventions right I might be
able to get some contingent conditions
but that's going to be completely
different or not completely it's going
to be significantly different
empirically so if that upper left is
Colorado's new energy economy right
contributing to maybe new instead of
Colorado's new energy economy Wyoming's
new energy economy and also to maybe
what Texas does for with its renewable
it's already has renewable energy
standards right so i think that the
conditions i can tell you about is how
that what goes on in one contributes to
the political dynamics and others I
don't know that I'm going to get to the
point where I can say this is going to
scale out when XYZ
chief I don't know if that makes sense
but maybe we will for the object as well
write this thing that's changing because
you started out by talking about unread
sort of unpacking it and talk about
different modes of carbon locket yes
right like summer summer infrastructure
tomorrow yes yeah I got your glory yes
now that yes and that we're trying to do
that's part of our case selection start
to be as diverse as possible we're
trying to look at ones from different
sectors as well as different
jurisdictional levels to try and try and
t some of that out absolutely that's
thank you the one system connector
you're not discussing is things going
backwards and important I think we've
seen trends and diverse themselves once
the news is child organization yeah
great idea twenty years ago bobby was
that abundantly partisan issues country
it is now and that greatly complicates
things happening at national girl yeah
and so one of the things that we're
really until I'm conscious the fact that
I gave you like the hopeful story of how
this could generate change I actually
think that that's the it's not the lower
probability of them but it certainly
isn't necessarily how it always is going
to happen and so one of the things it
but I think you can use this framework
to understand the generation of counter
coalition's that do exactly what you're
talking about so if you have successful
interventions right over time they scale
up the entrench but that doesn't change
that doesn't mean that they are not
susceptible to other intervention so the
vaccine one's really interesting so
essentially what you have with the
vaccine limit is we were locked into a
system where everybody just understood
that
should be vaccinated but then you get an
intervention that tries to disrupt that
you get Jenny McCarthy go ahead and you
get this terrible thing in Lancet that
ended up being completely false right
generating the kind of political
dynamics that would be counter
coalition's to which we might want right
and so I think that how this process
plays out so I think of it as a
providing a skeleton for how the
politics is playing out but then how
counter coalition's developed how you
get adaptation of mission and even
reversion depending upon what you're
looking at in terms of intervention is a
really important dynamic and we're
trying to think about that to lift that
way we have to Peter so I take oak of
them and I'll try to do
any lessons of seeing the c40 for
buildings city capital on state yeah i
think but let me take the other one too
and i'll do the mines until the question
okay the underlying culture the
jurisdiction that come into play
actually promote or facilitate the
implementation of the decarbonisation
wrecker is that you're talking about so
you know
you're not the answer the question but
it comes to mind is Copenhagen and the
egregious example or is it a typical
example now you have we have we have a
case of the time of people Republic of
China where you know decisions are made
entirely different fashion and yet
they're going forward yeah it's in
similar you know circuits and echoes and
so I think that there's two parts of it
is that you can think of social capital
or the underlying culture as both an
impetus for experimentation right and so
you're probably more likely to see the
kind of experimentation and progressive
or aggressive action in places that have
that and so it's really no surprise that
it's Denmark that it's Germany that it's
California right and so that's where you
can see the generation of leaders on
this and you're going to start to see
the first the pioneers in this right in
c40 you have some cities that move have
moved very quickly in fact they're the
ones that have found c40 and so in those
kind of initiatives the underlying
culture or political political social
capital ended up being generative of the
intervention itself more interesting and
less clear answers is thinking about
social capital political culture as the
end result of these interventions right
so how do you build on so you have a
level of political capital or social
capital that allows you to get started
doing things how once you start doing
things does that build a normative
community does that build a social and
political community that wants to do
more and that's where and so it plays
this dual role it's both an impetus and
potentially an outcome from this kind of
stuff and we're seeing both of those
like if you look at the stories of if I
was just giving an explanation for this
is work that I've done before explain
why some experience in jurisdictions
have climate experiments and others
don't it's you know social and political
capital and political cultures one is
is a key explanation for it the key for
this is to say okay that helps us
understand the initial leaders in the
fractal system how does that then carry
forward and how do we generate those
kind of social and normative communities
from interventions and that we're seeing
it happen i don't know that i've got
enough to give you very solid lessons on
it yet but thank you this was fun